[Music]
and bullied to death news no no I know
you do
hello that was a spare us around town
didn't answer the question
I don't know yet submitted by you boy
Zane Zane Zane a 23 year old porn
actress has taken her life after a major
backlash on Twitter dude I know this
story
oh good one I know is she was like the 9
or 13 year old like a really little girl
do porn star no not a person you mix the
two story I'm [ __ ] sure I know David
looked me in the eye Rinna yeah do you
know who August Ames is no I can't
believe David lied to me you just lied
to my face you pick that my my laptop
you don't know you know I know I know
this story do you know all these things
you swear it out in your life whose
August Ames
that's good I'm embarrassed that I don't
know Joe I know you don't know because
she doesn't have a dick okay the last
two porn stars that we were talking
about on JK news like I'm supposed to be
the porn encyclopedia and I feel like I
don't deserve that can I just be just
Frank right now I'm a flash porn guy I
mean I just don't look at the name it's
like hot hot hot you know I don't care
to know the name you know this is more
like it
I don't watch porn as much as I used to
so I'm [ __ ] out of it I'm talking
about like jenna jameson Tara Patrick
you like the amateur [ __ ] now yeah it's
more it's it's like a weapon on the ass
real you know it's more it's real I want
to see the real [ __ ] I don't want to see
that like high production fake [ __ ] like
yeah I want the real one
wow you're so sad oh that's like a
creepy and scary
I'm throwing big panties size nipples
I'm sad right now because I'm losing
this title of light brown hairs around
there hasn't taken a shower a couple
days I'm not talking about a hippie yeah
so porn stars August Eames she was 23
years old so yes I mean it I mean it
this is what for summer came out to be
like she's been in porn since 2003 yeah
that's all huh
it's their makeup mmm they know how to
make it up she has been in more than 270
films she's won two awards
congratulations on the porn Awards avian
avian yeah ha I knew that it's uh it's
sorted TIFF now so what's the M stand
for adult video Network I don't know
everyone just made that absolutely
don't settle for that I've never done me
neither
yeah so her death has been ruled a
suicide she hung herself
oh what a tough way to do yeah and it
seems like it's all because of backlash
that she received would fit sweets would
you like to read it yes whichever lady
performer is replacing me tomorrow for
at erotic X news you're shooting with a
guy who has shot gay porn just to let
you know the BS is all I can say
do agents really not care about who
they're representing hashtag la direct I
do my homework for my body nerd face
pencil emoji magnifying glass emoji I
understand that quite understand it
sounds like there's like some inside
information or is she like saying like
he's gay
she's pretty much just saying that she
will not do a scene or she will not be
performing with another performer who
she calls a crossover performer who has
done gay porn in the past and I was
doing straight porn oh she was just
pretty much like putting this person on
blast whoever she was supposed to
perform with
that they had shot gay porn in the past
and so it came off very like a lot of
people are saying that this came out
very homophobic and like what does she
have a problem with with people in the
gay performers she's a [ __ ] porn star
well now they're [ __ ] moral gods and
[ __ ] what I'm saying it's like you know
that people who asked like us youtubers
for our political views oh don't go to
me you have a responsibility David is
using you have use your platform David
oh [ __ ] don't know like is there some
kind of rivalry like hey you crossed
over from the gays you're not supposed
to be like that's like hood hop in like
yeah it used to be a blood and now
you're a [ __ ] so watch out for them
isn't crawl on Coral porn gay yeah has
she not done girl-on-girl yeah we might
be like unsaid porno rules yeah I just
[ __ ] like idea cop [ __ ] if you do
bondage stick with bondage yeah don't
cross over
oh no I do my research maybe the thing
like that yeah so I was reading the
replies to the this particular tweet and
so there were some people saying that in
for gay porn they don't have the same
same practices or like the same health
safety yes like health regulations
that's what some people were saying but
then other people are saying you're
stupid of course they do and so I tried
finding the answer I couldn't really
find it but they do pretty much say that
they do have to get tested but then
people they're saying that they don't is
that they don't have to get tested as
much because in gay porn they wear
condoms so in gay porn they don't even
get tested as much but then there's
other people saying no you're wrong
that's the misinformation you're
spreading misinformation so personally I
don't know what what the truth is here
Joe in gay porn do there were condoms
but his stuff is not gay porn though
it's women with dicks that's way
different I don't know how to [ __ ]
categorize that [ __ ] it makes me feel
like the most in frustrated I know I'm
not gay because I was watching a
gangbang and then they were doing the
girl and then this guy he just went down
and popped the dick into his mouth and I
was like oh
what's going on he popped the Dicky do
another guy's mouth so like so a guy was
are you sure you were watching a girl
game no no girl
so a girl was like giving it and then a
guy came behind her like that and then
like another guy came in and then
[ __ ] move the girls side and [ __ ]
of the century dude that's a big trip on
that's a big surprise Wow yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah and then like and then he just
he just [ __ ] move certain info like
hey that's not necessarily gay porn you
got caught up in the moment when you
[ __ ] a guy prison he's not gay yeah yeah
yeah hey work out kicks in yeah it's
like the record went correct for me he's
like [ __ ] why already started or - all
[ __ ] finish cuz usually if I'm in the
moment it's like oh well you know I just
keep going but that's how I know when I
watch that part I was like I'm sorry
this is not for me the guy that was
doing the [ __ ] did that like whitey
where the guy grab that guy's they can
put it in his mouth the guy I was doing
the [ __ ] go oh yeah I gets taking it
to the next level or as was he like whoa
but no no they they were like into it
like it was a part I think yes and see
it was just that but no I don't think I
get so fun while I'm mixing Joe right
he's watching it for like this he's like
oh yeah another scenarios doing the same
thing but they go like this like high
tide time exactly oh oh oh but that's
that just caught LA I didn't sign up for
this is one of those things like
and that's yeah that point on I stopped
watching gangbang pour it like it ruin
my dang days you don't know now it's
it's true ties yeah like I was just like
27 zip it up man stasis this is not what
I came here to do it's kind of cool so
the jacket goes here and then it goes oh
it's for Mexicans it goes here too what
are you going for that job interview I
don't know what my keys purpose was for
this is check it multi-culture Coco I
don't know what the purpose is but this
is the Nike market you could get it at
Nike store oh man I'm laughing so much
back to the girl who killed herself it's
like Jesus she's just saying like okay I
don't want to do a scene with this
person who was done that's because it
comes off or people are saying that like
it just came off very homophobic yeah it
was - I think on her and it was too too
vague and too insider yeah where people
were just cut it was left to
interpretation but it's also all these
porn fiends who follow her judging her
yeah which is one of the other porn
stars that were pretty much saying like
they were in this conversation other
poor says it so like for example were
talking earlier with that conversation
with how they do they don't have to get
tested or they do that was like porn
stars talking with intercourse so
basically she's not saying like I won't
[ __ ] him cuz he's gay he's like she's
like saying oh he's from that world and
it's dangerous so I got to protect
myself just in case she even ended it
that last line with um I I do homework
for my body for my body and get song
she's like I don't [ __ ] no gay guys like
I never did homework whether it's her
choice or not it's the way she worded
everything the way it came out it just
came off very anti-gay and so that's
that was the main reason although that's
true cuz then like the gay community
they have that stigma of the AIDS thing
like if you're gay then you have a
that was another are you
yeah okay I could see how that it could
be like that she's probably I don't know
how that testing so watch out you know
yeah but dude I mean you know and this
is not - Wow there's no okay whatever
porn stars are not like you know known
they're known for like like giving like
the best arguments about certain thing
you're not saying it's like not what
they do that's the best debaters right
she doesn't have to be you know is she
has a certain of word count to be as
articulate as she can be I don't know
man this you have to waste on send
emojis and stuff maybe people were
outraged because you know what Twitter
did they [ __ ] they gave a bigger
limit for a reason hmm so you could
explain himself bet or these dudes I
used to look up to you and then now I
judge them that's right yeah that's
[ __ ] up yeah but why shouldn't she be
able to choose who she Fugs yeah some
youtubers I want to work with Viners my
body my choice dawg
yeah cuz what if she's like you know
what uh just no skinny guys like I'll
[ __ ] everybody but no skin what if a
girl what if the points are going what
if a porn star girl was to tweet I don't
[ __ ] corn stars because the Dixon way
too big but like you don't saying but
she's just like I don't [ __ ] my quarters
oh yeah that's like oh [ __ ] oh but she
didn't put that because right but to see
that she maybe she didn't articulate the
reason why it's just like I don't [ __ ]
like porn stars and it's like oh [ __ ]
even though she did give them because
there's still be people I get angry cuz
like not all like I said big day like
yeah I love how people would argue
against it done hey not all guys have
that gift I'm like I and I don't have a
big dick at all I love how that works
like I love that no I'm just being [ __ ]
anyway I'm just arguing the other side
just for success but then it tripped her
out that much that she had a killer so
it's sad well I mean that seems to be
like the only good people were like you
[ __ ] homophobe
but she can't live with that but she
could live with 4,000 dicks to the Bell
I mean I'm pretty sure there's like 200
videos more to the reason as to why
maybe she was having a bad day too and
that was this just said just set it off
on her own
yeah yeah yeah she was already dealing
with depression inches her very last
tweet that she tweeted out was [ __ ]
y'all yeah
so she was she'd it was definitely a
reaction to the to the Twitter bullying
for sure cuz you have to be kind of
tough to be a porn star like you know
the the stigma that's attached people
saying [ __ ] people guys always like I
wanna come on your face off just like
that video you know dude every guy
thinking that they can [ __ ] you yeah
like it's true like that's what they
think like I know I know couple porn
stars from videos and stuff oh yeah
because you did the yeah bang bus pranks
and [ __ ] yeah they're there they guys
really do think that porn stars want to
[ __ ] all the time I think they really
think that [ __ ] like in these ports our
girls are telling me that and like some
of them one of the girls was like I
don't even [ __ ] like doing anal
afternoon ain't seen her mom so [ __ ]
pissed big bucks right but we're all
just like oh yeah she left in the book
yeah I know she do look I bet you really
enjoy it yeah there's money involved
yeah we don't
that's why I'll watch like
high-production porn it's not authentic
man I could tell
[Music]